if any of you need anything at all too
bad
deal with your problems yourselves like
adults I don't understand I was great I
was like Mark Z in the social and my
testimony was amazing for your case but
it wasn't the truth and neither was
yours you even called me a vegetarian
what if that testimony leaks how will
people ever respect me
whatever the truth is stupid I only tell
the truth when it makes me sound like
I'm lying yeah lying is all I know it's
how I was able to scrape by on the
streets of Bombay and make it on the
Indian version of Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire and get reunited with the
love of my life
both take a lesson from Andrew he told
the truth about everything he was asked
even when it was humiliating for him
that's right I love telling the truth
case in point sometimes when I blow my
nose I get a boner I don't know why it
just happens truth bomb
I'm gonna call you both back in that
room and you'll recant your testimony no
you committed perjury but more
importantly you've Dishonored yourselves
oh brother
they are so young so much to learn
what are you talking about I know right
wisdom
you know when I was 12 my brother shot
me in the pinky toe with a nail gun
granted it was a hilarious prank and we
all had a good laugh that's awful but I
avoided going to the doctor I hate
paperwork
after a few weeks the toe just kind of
fell off you only have nine toes I have
the toes I have
let's just leave it at that
the point is the doctor said if I had
come in right away they might have saved
the toe
you can't run away from your problems
especially if you only have nine toes
sorry that was uncalled for
I'm Ron Swanson and you're Leslie nope
you with me
do you fish April no fish are gross let
me give you a piece of fishing advice I
said when you have a fish on the line
you don't just drag it behind the boat
you either reel it in or you cut them
loose especially if he's a nice fish
with a big lovable fish heart you don't
know what you're talking about Maybe not
maybe you really do hate Andy maybe
moving to Indianapolis just to get
revenge on him is a really good idea
what do I know
[Music]
and now officially insist that you take
a sabbatical no no let me finish
I used to work in a sheet metal Factory
but then a job came along at the Tannery
the hours were better and I would get
paid also I'd have the chance to work
with leather both before and after it
was on the cow which had always been a
dream of mine
I didn't want to give up my sheet metal
job so I tried to do both jobs and
finish Middle School how old were you
11.
point is I was so tired
I tried to puncture an 8 gauge aluminum
foil with a leather awl
wow I learned a lesson
never half-assed two things
whole ass one thing
so if you want to win that seat which I
do
and commit yourself 100 percent
get sabbatical
I will cut back to 10 hours a week
deal
15. 10.
I hired you to do one thing
just one
I don't care that you text all day and
sleep at your desk in fact I encourage
it but only because you were doing that
one thing
keeping this crap off my desk
give me five minutes before the next one
next one that guy is scary when he's
angry I got him though hey sorry dude I
don't need your sympathy
or yours I wasn't offering my sympathy
I think
[Applause]
that was it right uh no there's one more
damn it to hell it's with me and it's
right now and it's about me quitting
I quit
why are you here
come back to work
nah
come back
I want you to come back well I don't
want to come back
the end
I was talking to Andy about you and he
made me realize that I need you back at
work what did he say don't recall fine
I'll come back
good
okay I'm leaving
bye Zuzu
bye Duke silver
my mom has all your albums
I recognize you the day we met
have you told anyone no
good girl
this mural is called bad Pawnee good
Pawnee all the terrible things that have
happened in this town's history are on
one side and on the other side are all
the good things that have happened
I'm on the bad side no you're not yes I
am Ron I'm guilty I did something bad
I'm a bad person
it's not that simple
you know what makes a good person good
when a good person does something bad
they own up to it
they try to learn something from it and
they move on
you're gonna take a college course
Andrew you should explore a new subject
broaden your horizons and Horizons are
dominant never broaden your horizons yep
just take something you're great at and
get an easy a no offense Ron but April's
way sounds way easier
guitar for beginners I value a good
education so I don't want to see Andy
waste his time in College of all my
co-workers he is one of a small number
whom I do not actively root against
all right there I go getting all sappy
we will be working on basic chords for
the first four weeks
of course you are you're not challenging
yourself I suggest we sample a few more
classes
[Music]
this is what I was secretly an
undercover rock star this whole time
you're the only reason we all still have
jobs I think we'll be okay yeah okay
well I would love to chit chat about
this but I need to keep working okay and
keep pushing so that my breakthrough
will happen and I will be ready for it
you know what I just had an idea for a
new project really yes
yes I think I think this could be really
good what is it
come with me right through here wait
what's happening clap
This Is My Idea you're gonna shut your
brain down and go to sleep and I'm gonna
stay out here and guard the door so you
can't leave
you've been thinking about work
I'll due respect Miss clack stick a
German muffin in it
in fact Leslie the transom is painted
shut damn it
oh my God there's like 50 cats in here
where's Leslie not a hundred percent
sure should we reschedule or nope she'll
be here
a little disoriented but
in ideas and Ron would not let me have
any paper so I had to write them down on
this doily we should buy a telescope and
make the old ranger station in Ramsey
Park an observatory that way we could
sell tickets and have class trips I like
it good we have seen night at the park
we could have singles um date night
seniors and we could have a city-wide
yard sale which would be part auction
part Antiques Roadshow and then we could
have the professors from the community
college come in and assign value to the
objects and then we could split the
profits into school it'd be a lot of fun
let's see you boys later